I know
good evening everybody nice to see you
all and welcome
um
um we're also expecting any fire drills
um so
if you fire alarm just sound then you
need to make our way out
um by the nearest trailer for exit which
I think is just a big smile right
um I've received apologies from
councilor Bennett councilor Acton and
councilor Paul
um I'm not aware of any of this
um we've also had apologies from Tracy
Arnold who is the head of service cared
for and Care experienced children young
people but Mike Kelly has kindly come
despite the fact that he's got a ticket
for the match
that's above and beyond
um
so I will try and finish so you can at
least get to the second half
okay and are there any decorations of
Interest
[Music]
foreign
and I'm not aware that we have any
questions from the public this time
which last time I think we had 13
questions which was highly unusual
um has everybody had a chance to have a
look at the minutes of the previous
meeting and are we happy to
um pass on this correct
okay
so I'm going to move on to the um the
next agenda item I'm going to hand over
to Mike
um sorry chair I've got a correction
um my name is Miss speltz frequently
through the documentary
um it's Proctor ending in ER that is
frequently spelled Proctor oh really
yeah
I'm the only reason it matters so much
is that if someone sends an email to me
start Block tour I won't receive it
right okay thank you thank you
um I'm going to hand over to Mike so we
have had site of the presentation so
what I would say is if you could just
give us a Whistle Stop guide through
what you've got on the screen because we
do like the opportunity to ask questions
device
thank you and so this is a presentation
which is written by Tracy
from the world today and so it will look
at the corporate parenting strategy in
relation to preparation of travelhood
um
we'll hope you talked about how our
young people tell us about their
experiences
um
give you a brief over your National
Mutual picture legal framework
how we measure our performance and our
next steps and the plans for the future
so the concepts for supporting all R
Kelly was is embedded in the children's
living Care Act which are located 2000
came into force on the 1st of October
2001 and prior to the children's care I
should say lots of human people lost
contact with their own local authorities
upon leading care many local authorities
didn't know their care leaders local
term is provided what could be described
as a reactive service one which respond
to the only person got in contact rather
than a proactive service built on
relationships and solid future planning
which is what the emphasis is within the
children reading Care Act to keep in
touch and to build strong plans for
young people
so the ACT talks about how we should
help young people how we should support
them movement from care and to living
independently
it identifies the time to support if
both the duty on the local authority to
assess and meet the need to player
experience young people
and
in effect it is The Benchmark and it
legislates and declines the corporate
clearance responses up to the age of 25.
an interactive this means doing what we
do for our children parents in simply
doesn't end
perfect
and so the legal framework the children
needed Care Act queer definitions around
eligibility which I'll cover in the next
slide requirement for All Care leaders
that are tough week one and
elected members will be aware and will
have heard before of care plans for
cared for children halfway plan is the
Drone next time if you like it's what
supersedes the care plan at age 16 in
three months and becomes the ambition of
the future planning for a young person
at the age of 21 or 25.
um
and the actors also talk about requires
that young people are assigned a
personal advisor
and it also stipulates the the client
assistance with important Education and
Training
however what we know nationally locally
and region is that providing the right
support at the right time to care if
they're in strong people can be
challenging
so what does that mean in effect in
effect it means we have a duty to visit
our young people a minimum of eight
weeks and
um
the pathway plan
that supersedes the care plan covers
education training employment
accommodation identity and culture
emotional well-being
healthy social care
relationships finances and independent
living skills
so the leading Care Act defines and
shows the eligibility for those young
people who are able to access a leading
Care Service which is there in detail I
don't propose to go to it go through it
unless someone wants me to but in effect
if you are eligible you work through to
relevant and then former relevant and
then there are qualifiers who have spent
a brief period cared for
um so those are the four main
eligibility criteries
so there's been National and Regional
work done around care leading
um there was research undertaken by
Austin or Ready or Not
um which highlighted that for many young
people in care the fact that approaching
Agriculture and leading the care system
has been a time of moving on and that
their Ambitions and plans for the future
are often really challenged by their own
anxieties and their fears are moving on
more than a third of care leaders felt
they weren't ready to leave care and
that was often because of the move out
of care happened abruptly and they were
not ready for all the changes
of those who didn't feel that you left
Care at the right time not all felt that
they have the required skills to live
independently
so the key things we didn't care too
early in the sense of isolation and fear
not feeling involved in their pathway of
planning or having choices in their
accommodation pulse leading care
feeling unprepared to manage money
unlimited understanding of their writing
entitlement
and
it is felt that good relationships with
personal advisor if they're introduced
early so there's a chance to make a
relationship before leaving here
they feel that often that is the best
way rather than coming in late and
nearer to their age of 18 and leading
care
so our prayer leaders our care leads in
Trafford our care experiencing people
told us very similar things
they tell us that sometimes it feels
like care leaves us rather than we leave
care and it can feel like a cliff Edge
they want Clarity on what they're
entitled to and that is outlined in the
care leader often which we will talk
about later
they would like more options around
their housing and accommodation post 18.
they won't continue to support to access
support from Health Partners post equity
and they speak possibly about their
personal advisors which is great to hear
probably I've challenged us further at
corporate parenting kind of in terms of
they want clarity about what the
protected characteristic means
and they're critically
um
sorry
and we are needing to take action and
respond to those challenges through our
corporate parenting strategy which now
is a clear priority in respect of
preparing care leaders rather put
so the strategy
um sets out a commitment and an
intention for careful children and a key
principle of that strategy is would this
be good enough for my child which kind
of um probably goes back to a famous
letter written by Frank Dawson in 1998
which basically said
um we should all be thinking about wood
looked at a child with our child
[Music]
the concept of a child a son or a
daughter coming home and tapping you up
for a tenor or wanting to really
watching and it's that principle of
corporate parenting that we should be
there for the long term sort of under
the preparing from the priority we're
committing to engage with
um
greater Manchester care leader groups
um to try and shape Service delivery for
not only our care expansion people but
for those that cross-grade the
Manchester and to try and get a
consensus and some agreement on there
being
not a postcode Lottery book some
uniformed approach to the office that
each Council offers their care expansion
people and we we attend regular meetings
with colleagues across GM and we've
updated Our Fair leader offer uh so that
their support and the content of that
are clear and that they understand them
and that will be formally launched in
care leader week which is the same week
every year for those who don't know and
that's the week of the 23rd of October
this year and we will also share the uh
Kelly Ruffin with professionals next
week during Social Work practice with
we're looking to improve the quality of
our pathway plans for all young people
and there's an under ongoing group
addressing those issues around halfway
plans and we're working alongside
colleagues in Adult Services to try and
develop a clear pathway into Adult
Services for those young people with
vulnerabilities we have met tries to
begin that that piece of work and we
want to ensure that all providers
whether they're Foster carers
residential workers or supported
accommodation providers work alongside
our young people in in gain skills
independent skills by using an agreed
document the independent living skills
handbook which has currently being
updated and that is the document which
hosts
the housing option service in Trafford
and uses to assess whether a young
person is tenancy ready
um we have a house project which I'll
discuss later and we want as part of our
work to look at identifying suitable
even people for that project
we want to implement an accommodation
panel for young people to focus on their
Transitions and Readiness for
independent living and that will give
Focus to that age range of young person
and take away from what is now a generic
placement panel where their issues are
discussed alongside the other young
people
and I said before we want to explore the
health of the Care expansion people and
adults Pro stages
there are a number of data in the report
which I don't particularly propose to go
through but it does show that um
we have a ongoing
um
number of young people in the 10 to 15
age bracket who will be coming through
to leave and care services in the coming
years and despite performance having
reduced recently the um the number of
young people within are cared 4 numbers
will go on to require legal care
services
and that data shows those who are
eligible so the the dates on the left
box is indicating that there are 21 in
yellow
predicted will become eligible out of
26. 41 predicted to become eligible 43.
so we know that those numbers are going
to continue to rise and that we will
need ongoing good quality leading care
services
um
so um
moving forward we want to introduce a um
an opt-out model for young people rather
than an opt-in model in terms of working
with young people post 21 you want to be
able to offer them A continuing service
it may well be a tapered Service as they
go from 21 to 25 but nonetheless we want
to keep in touch and have meaningful
relationships continued over 21.
um
so this means we will be actively
supporting more young people for a
longer period of time
so how will we measure our performance
well
keeping in touch so I said earlier that
we need to keep in touch at least a
minimum of once every eight weeks we
judge ourselves on that we judge
ourselves on those who are in education
training and employment and we do have
successes we do have young people who've
gone to University want to do Masters
delay levels but you know we need to
keep pushing that can never be enough we
want more and more young people to put
outcomes from their education and to
find success in the work the workplace
and we also measured by a suitable
accommodation
um and clearly that is a solid
foundation for anyone starting out in
the world to have a good quality
suitable accommodation we absolutely do
not accept that custody
no fixed Abode or better than breakfast
could ever be deemed as suitable and we
attract those young people either
alongside our colleagues in the youth
Justice service or Probation Services or
by reports in fact on those in unsuitful
community provisions
and we do that up to director level
so what are the general accommodation
options for young people when they turn
um well as Khalid mentioned earlier
there and staying put staying puts an
arrangement where young people and their
Foster cares
um in agreement where a university can
choose to stay there for you know a
post-dated team
um and we do well in traffic we have
strong numbers in that area supportive
lodgings we have a forward lodging
scheme which provides in people in a
room in their of their own in a private
home whether they're a member of the
household and we have low numbers in
lodges but we are looking to almost do
all that by March 2024 and we have um
two accommodation options I think we've
actually got three with Mary house which
are provisioned for four young people we
have Forest Court which is a provision
for five young people and we have L
Street Corp which is another provision
chapter for 16 people
I briefly returned to the house project
so that is a new project which
um originally was set up in Manchester
and we in Trafford have come alongside
the house project and we are now
entering our second cohort of young
people to have gone through the scheme
um the first program has seen a cohort
of seven young people three are
currently in their own home their own
sentences further to are identified and
waiting to move into their new build
properties the um the high point there
is a link to a photograph of the young
person and with that key going into
their new flat um
pointed and we've identified a third of
seven young people for the second cohort
um
there are then a couple of photographs
of a celebration event of the house
project where human people have come to
the end of the I think it's a nine month
program of work around becoming tendency
ready
photographs
[Music]
so what we've done today we've created a
service improvement plan which is in
place and overseen by the corporate
director we have regular care lever
Assurance meetings with again of the
corporate director chair in that because
we know there's a lot of work to be done
and there's a lot of checks and balances
of need to ensure that we are doing as
we say we're going to do we've
established the links with great and
Manchester uh Kelly the delivery group
with power and with Salford Council for
a sector-led Improvement around care
experiencing people and we had a two-day
training session led by the Salford
reading Care Service who are voted as
good with outstanding features by ofsted
and they um concentrated on on a company
design seeking children so that's triple
planning for young people whether they
move on into getting instead you know um
permission to remain or whether they end
up
eventually being deported back to their
own country so it's a way of shaping the
plans that every outcome is considered
we looked at um the care that young
people and support that young people who
are parents need and the importance of
us looking onto the corporate
grandparent at that child of the young
adult and make making sure that young
child is thriving and we also looked at
those young people in custody and
ensuring that we develop stronger
relationship to the youth Justice
service the probation service in
ensuring safe discharge from custodial
settings
um we've reviewed the care offer as
mentioned before with young people the
council has brilliantly introduced a
protected characteristic around
careful and Care expansion people and we
as a service have done a targeted
recruitment of Staff with care
experience expertise
so we have more to do that's the message
we have more to do to improve the
service
um so what do you want to do we're going
to deliver a corporate parenting
strategy link to the preparation for
adulthood and we're going to do it well
we're going to link some of our Adult
Services colleagues we're going to link
alongside our
other partners alongside health and
ensure that young people with
vulnerabilities are able to get ongoing
services
we're going to create an induction
program for all our newly appointed
staff ensure that staff have consistent
support to division and management we're
going to training and staff on
legislation guidance to care lever offer
but also that Kelly roughly is about to
all other staff residential staff foster
care social workers across the
children's social care who want to offer
support in relation to protected
characteristic and we are currently
undertaken some legal advice as to what
that actually means what the parameters
are as a council in terms of what we can
offer care experience in people and the
leader of the council is arranging a
event for key Employers in the city and
to promote employment opportunities for
care experiencing people
we want to strengthen the quality of
pathway plans and we want to develop
review and quality assure the whole
service
and it's any questions
thanks Mike does anybody have any
questions
councilor Hurst
um
the first thing that I wanted to ask was
about Pas and whether
um if you know how many care Neighbors
from age 18 to 21 have a continuous PA
throughout that time what nutrition rate
is like
I'm sorry I I don't know the the figures
and what I would say is that as a
service we've had
a large turnover of that over time we
have recruited in recent months and we
are now seeing a period of stability
however the well I would say in terms of
the page run social Works we've had more
stability in that area of the service
um so some young people have had the
same pH throughout others will about
changes which is regretable but that is
the market that they're working in terms
of attention
yeah absolutely
there's the numbers of Pas
I think social work yeah over between 18
or 21 yeah absolutely
um you also mentioned eight week to
visit
is that face to face the text message
challenge
No it should be face to face and so
um
altered their practices and
zoom calls for team calls technology and
place time was seen as acceptable
practice given
the way the country was locked down we
we're saying very clearly that should be
face to face eight weeks now there are
some exemptions now where even people
maybe other than in London or far afield
but we might say alternate agree face to
face and maybe one of those is over Zoom
or photo time but know that it should be
face to face with the minimum front end
is the target for that happening
right okay I I'll take that that is
definitely not in place
um and in terms of pathway times
that if they've got an allocated PA
there should be a pathway plan in place
that pathway plan is being developed as
I said earlier we are looking to try and
improve the the layout and the pro form
and the questions are more
kind of considered you know not a yes no
answer much more qualified
about what I mean
I mean
absolutely absolutely the only person
yes absolutely in person and then any
other professional that's involved as
long as you've got the resolution of the
universal today would be an adult
thank you
[Music]
um
you set them you'd collected views of
care leaves I just wondered how you've
done that
um so we consulted with bleeding care or
Aftercare form which is run by our
Advocate service which means directly at
the Dawson Studios so that's the group
that we can sort with directly and how
many of the young people who are care
leaders engaged
and it's
between six and eight
how do you get responsible
at that time
responses into uh you know the voice of
their their voice
as a minimum so they will be gathering
their
um voice their Indian their responses to
a number of factors that we asked when
we when we do visits in their contacts
and how have they shared it with
something like this
well the their voices are incorporated
into their pathway funds as an
individual if they're raising issues of
concern or raising issues of points
where we could improve services that
will be fed in
um via the the PA where we have a talk
to everyone the care leader of the dean
formerly launched on the either the 23rd
of October we will be Distributing that
to every care leader they will get
it will be going on to
um great to Manchester's got a mobile
app called be as indeedably be connected
it will be launched on the app so there
will be opportunities for young people
to look at that it will be reviewed
regularly the care leader often their
input is always welcome we can never
have enough representation a voice of
young people in six to eight
um is what we've had brilliantly
um but to get a real measure we need we
need bigger numbers for not every other
person wants to or can't say it work not
everyone is available
right that's a really good point and I'd
say that back to our colleagues and the
advocacy service and that's who's
considered whether there might be a
different format for that group yeah and
maybe after them
share with me any details that might be
letting the person you're thinking of
diary
yeah thank you Mike can I just I said
what a good people waiting
um that have questions so counselors
uh thank you John thank you for the
report there just on the first point on
the phases of relevance
I think the language we're using around
that is is not where it needs to be
frankly
um and just a specific point on um
how how a young person moves from moves
to former relevant status about just the
wording on the slide wasn't wasn't great
but just just to give a bit of context
about how how what trick is someone
moving from relevant to foreign
there's a site on the voice of our
careers section which is about
um young people telling us they would
like more options in terms of Housing
and accommodation I know the financial
sport is not really uh the entire
umbrella when it comes to
contact I'm just conscious of you've got
any data that you're able to offer
around
um how many caregivers are paying
council tax in traffic at the moment
who are under the age of 25
no
no are you able to provide that no
there's no no there's none of their
exempts from Council service right okay
so it's not a discretionary relief it's
an exact form exemption
I don't know the technical the way
you're describing those words Caroline
is under the age of 25. I do not pay
council tax I've been attracted in order
to pay so it is a technical distinction
but I think it is discretionary uh
scheme that we have in traffic so I'm
just just yeah that's the whole the
whole great to manage to assigned
okay
and so can I just go back to the point
you made around the eligibility legal
framework
that was that what you would describe so
yeah I'm talking about the former former
relevant status particularly and just
for my own context there what what moves
a care lever from into that okay do you
want me to explain that to you the best
players yeah so um you become eligible
and these terms are from the ACT these
are the terms that we have to work with
you become eligible if you've spent a
period of 13 weeks or more from the age
of 14 which includes at least one night
over the age of 16. you become an
eligible child
if you leave care having been eligible
before the age of 18 you become relevant
and post 18 you become former relevant I
understand exactly what you described in
terms of someone being relevant or not
relevant it does sound wrong but that's
the words lifted from the two million
carrot
thank you
thank you um that was one of my
questions is it possible that we could
maybe not use phrases like formally
relevant and relevant or is that just
not the done thing I just I find it
quite jarring to have a person described
as previously relevant or relevant it's
an eligibility state to slow down in law
and those other kind of language that
we're using with our young people who
are care experienced it's on our system
that they are those words are used in
our system to say are they eligible for
care leading Services what criteria do
they meet
it's not something we use day to day we
wouldn't be we talk about young people
being care experienced okay and the um
additional thing that I wanted to um ask
about was about and when they move on to
it I think it's great that some I've
moved on to higher and further education
what is the link between Trafford and
those educational institutes is it is it
incumbent on the
um on the young person announcing their
status
to in order to access kind of additional
support that there is available or how
does that work so on the um the form
that we fill in the youth principle
there is a question about have you ever
been in public care
and I think there's a little sentence
alongside that
we encourage young people to think about
that
by ticking that box it opens up a number
of avenues or character into people it
opens up access to bursaries opens up
access to mentors it opens access to a
number of things that the universities
who and many of them have got trust
cagmark award for their extra support
their efforts care leaders
it is something that they can actually
receive additional
positive experiences from buying
declaring their status but a young
person doesn't have to that's entirely
their their choice but it does open
avenues that the university wants to get
them extra and then just one last thing
where do if children have not been able
to return to their families and their
University or at higher education where
do they go for the like 13 weeks of the
year when they're not in University
accommodation is it is it our
responsibility to house them and if so
where did we do that absolutely yeah 52
weeks a year so um non-certain time we
especially obliged to provide Foundation
building to University are going from
Foster Care to University it's fairly
rare that when people go from
residential children's home to
university many of those going to
University from Foster Care are
[Music]
in good relationships with their Foster
cares and utilize the staying put the
engine and for those human people the
form of foster care is now the right
supported
same cut provider is paid pro-raptor so
they come home every weekend or they
come home denying me to join summer or
three weeks at Easter they are paid
pro-rata to this day of that in person
and it's an incredible thing that
prosecutors do to extend that offer and
it's really important to our parents to
stability for others they may
they may not have fun as you said and we
would pay 52 weeks accommodation at the
University or at the in the second year
at the Shared house so we do and we have
to provide all year round accommodation
yeah thank you very much indeed
um
it is clear that all members are doing
their utmost to improve the service
itself thank you very much
um
what is evidence is that these young
adults would like help with going into
the adult life
they've had insecurities that no one
help with offering the best possible
packages going into
uh adulthood
um
what's been read tonight on the screen
these elements are telling us and I
quote
they tell us that sometimes it feels
like care leads us rather than we leave
care
and the document highlighted tonight
um
also quotes that um
you've moved to an opt out
option rather than an act in model
um so therefore to me
this phrase opt out seems to be a
contradiction it goes against how
they're actually feeling
so I'm actually wondering whether that
phrase opt out
can be reconsidered I know it sounds
silly
and I've read it prior to coming tonight
and I've had it with other people it
just seems a little bit
as if you're leaving them out to me
whoever's putting that phrase for it I'm
just wondering whether that can be
reconsidered absolutely it's a term that
has been used
um
within within uh discussions we've had
and it it's not meant to be
um in any way shape or form
misunderstood but it is it's evolved
down the fact that we want to keep human
people when Tim was to 25 so it's the
kind of the notion that unless they opt
out we're holding on to until 25
absolutely upset it can be misread and
I'll say that back
shooters
um you mentioned before about
um
face-to-face meetings and of course was
a big part in
um
not happening
are all members of Staff know carrying
out face-to-face meetings with young
adults are they they've been told no
that must happen or is it still
sometimes in some cases being done
remotely thank you
um no they've all been told it's face to
face they all understand it's a minimum
of eight weeks
um there are exceptions that I described
before to you Colleen in terms of
distance sometimes we might elect to say
actually practically maybe every second
eight weeks and the other one be over
Zoom or FaceTime whichever it means we
sometimes have difficulty getting into
prisons if someone at times have
difficulty locating young people if
they've moved and not let us know but
it's face to face that that's the
message clear to stuff
okay thank you thank you
I think we've got time for one more
question
um councilman Park
um thank you
um the it says in the report that the
majority of 18 to 21 year olds are
living with parents or relatives or
independent living and is this by of
choice and is or is it is it about like
having no lack of an alternative option
or is and the other question relating to
that skilled Partners impression is is
the level of support through the pathway
plan influenced or impacted by weapons
were accommodated
yeah so
um
you you picked up there from the the
dates that young people do
choose to go back home
um young people not at all still agree
that they were ever removed from the
family and maintain contact whilst being
cared for and some
[Music]
it's influenced
uh who had relationships are with it's
influenced by
everything
um
and maybe you know ensure that
some of the issues that perhaps resulted
in them not living with their parents
some years ago may or may not
disappeared on the way together
circumstances choice and we work with
that and we developed a pathway plan in
accordance
thank you
parents
it's about ambition and it's about
aspiration and it's about wanting
foreign
um
and they're absolutely fabulously
um care leavers that come out like you
know they're confident and outgoing and
everything you would want them to be
um but thank you for the report thank
you for stepping again thank you very
much wishes to uh Tracy for a speed y
all right I mean more than
I'm more than happy for you together
[Music]
just before we go on to the next item if
you don't mind I'm sorry it's remiss of
me I haven't asked the officers here
this evening to introduce themselves so
can we start with councilor Carter
thank you councilor Western my name is
councilor Karina Carter and I am the
lead member for children young people
and these are all the fabulous people
that work really hard to support me and
my role
getting in Trafford on an interim basis
and with a sound Improvement plan as the
send Improvement these some particularly
to talk about the transition
foreign
Karen samples Director of Education for
Trafford
thanks good evening Sully Smith her wcm
inclusion
hi good evening Sarah and assistant
director of nursing and quality for NHS
greater Manchester
evening I'm a brown director of adults
um
so I'm not sure this is going to be
sunny
again we have company
can I make a request please
it's me can everyone move their
microphones much nearer to them when
they speak because these are not really
good microphones and they only pick your
voice up when you're six inches away
thank you
hopefully can you can you hear me now is
that that better yeah okay
okay so I will do a real Whistle Stop
tour of this uh report because we've had
lots of people that actually contributed
to it because we tried to cover not just
PFA but also elements of transition from
early years right into
um reception in year one year six to
year seven
um as as well as preparing for adulthood
and moving into uh sort of post 16 post
18. and hopefully what's clear in this
report is that transition is a priority
for us in Trafford and it's it's
absolutely a priority for our children
young people and families and and we've
actually
um brokered in some external validation
that has taken place over the last 12
months where it's been made clear that
we have work to do to improve this part
of the work and just make sure that our
families and young people are supported
at all of those key points in in their
lives and in the report I've discussed
the ambition plan that we have in send
with ambition for being one of our main
transition priorities and that priority
is all about ensuring that our children
we send and our young people have
exactly the same opportunities a little
bit about what councilor Western was
just sharing then as all young people
and so that they can have exactly the
same life outcomes
um what I've shared in the report is
some of the code of practice so some of
the background legislative stuff that
sits behind transition and also describe
the elements of preparing for adulthood
which is absolutely about preparing
young people for education and or
employment
um supported to achieve Independent
Living ensuring that they can
participate fully in society that they
can contribute within their communities
and that they have those supporting
friendships and relationships around
them and being as healthy as possible in
their adult life and those are all
outcomes that we seek to highlight and
mature and a child or young person's
Education Health and Care plan
so I've talked about starting early so
this is absolutely around ensuring that
that early identification appropriate
support and intervention is put into
place particularly in the early years
because that's key to to securing
lifelong success for our children and
young people and we're really committed
to a program of professional development
particularly for early years service
providers those in pvis in our
independent nurseries and our early
years settings around send we have quite
a significant percentage of
um practitioners that work in those pvis
and nurseries who have actually achieved
the level three senko award so we're
really making sure we try and support
and Target the workforce to equip them
with meeting needs for our very young
children
we have quite a strong transition
pathway from early years into schools
that's that's well managed and there's
lots of
partners and professionals can work
together in the summer term to discuss
children who may need some additional
transition support and that support can
be provided from our send advisory
Service as well as other professionals
as well and it's enabling families to be
advised and supported in identifying
which which is the best place for their
children to to actually transition into
as well and guidance around providers
actually our early years advisor was
talking to her earlier this week she's
actually going around with to all of our
primary schools to talk to early years
leads and heads as well and to really
consider some of the barriers that some
of our very young children are facing as
they're going into school and also
discussing how we can really improve and
incentivize inclusive practice to make
sure that we can identify and meet need
at an earlier stage
and so that's something around
um early years and I have put in there
some of our early years outcomes as well
which hopefully reflects some of the
sick
of this improvements we've
um at a good level of development in the
reception but also the year one phonics
check at the end of year one we've seen
a real um Improvement in the outcomes
for those children as a result of that
targeted support
I then go on to talk about the year 60
year seven we know in traffic transition
into secondary school is it's an
interesting picture in Trafford it's a
complex area just because of the nature
of the educational system that we have
in Trafford and and Shona and I uh we
were with Trafford parent caring Forum
this morning at St Matthews in their
Community Center one of their coffee
morning events and it was really clear
that transition was a key theme that
came out in some of the discussions that
we had in families and I then went on to
meet the head of a new head at sale High
interestingly this afternoon and we had
a long conversation about send and
inclusive practice particularly in the
secondary sector so I'm really trying to
Bang the Drum for that in particular in
our secondary schools because that's
where we do see a spike in terms of
requests for
EHC plans because I think there is a
real panic and a real worry and anxiety
about what lies ahead for for young
people and so there's certainly
something that we we continue need to be
committed on and certainly working with
our sun consultants and senkos and head
teachers we have an inclusion
collaborative which we'll be driving for
the inclusion Charter which is
absolutely about trying to support
schools to be equipped with the skills
that they need to be more inclusive and
meet the needs of our children and young
people
and I then go on to talk about
preparation for adulthood and as I say
this is a report that has been pulled
together from lots and lots of Partners
and I preferred there to the external
validation which was completed by Paula
Thompson Jones who is Ascend inspector
and we deliberately commissioned her
because we wanted the mirror to be held
up to really show exactly what what it
was like in Trafford and where we need
to improve and I've shared a summary of
the findings there which you can imagine
will not have been an easy read for you
and it certainly wasn't an easy read for
us it wasn't easy to hear some of the
messages that Paula delivered but
we have absolutely embraced it and we
are absolutely committed to making sure
we get the right improvements in place
and and this is certainly part and
parcel and I've shown a being seconded
in to work with us to really help drive
forward those improvements that's needed
the lived experience panels the elite
panels as we call them was something
that Trafford parent care forum set up
it's been a brilliant brilliant
opportunity to really hear the lived
experience and PFA was one of the lead
panels one of the most recent ones that
we had and again in the report you can
see some of the themes that emerged from
the lived experience from our families
you can see the you know mental health
is is a real concern for families
particularly during transition and
transitioning into adulthood and having
to tell their story repeatedly all the
time to different people is frustrating
for our families and communicate the
whole communication engagement
piece is is something that parents meal
needs to be strengthened as well as
making sure that we start earlier
because I think again I you know might
refer to in his presentation the feeling
of being on the cliff Edge we know that
our families describe PFA as being on a
cliff Edge and not really understanding
what lies ahead and it being done too
late or you know that that's certainly
when we start commencing and providing
the right Professional Service so
ambition for which I then share is
absolutely around driving forward those
improvements
to try to summarize some of the pathways
that were in place the independent the
neighborhood and complex I won't go
through those hopefully you've had a
chance to read those and also some of
the work of the supported internships
and Employment Group and I think that's
really strengthened over the last few
months we've had funding in and there's
a an improvement plan and action plan
that's sitting around employability and
the use of supported internships in
Trafford which is really positive move
and going forward
um I have shared some bits around key
stage four outcomes for our same
children just so that you get a flavor
of the educational outcomes for children
at the end of key stage four and post 16
and it's interesting our children too
well our children we send continue to do
well despite some of the challenges that
they might have and so you know that's
that's a positive thing that we are
managing to maintain
um in Trafford I think the most
important section really is the last
section which is what good transition
will look like and this is pulling
together everything that we've
identified and put into our ambition
plan for which Shona is the lead which
honestly she might be here for six
months it may end up being six years I
think I think a family member a family
person said this morning and it could
well be that the way we're going
um but we're really clear we've as I say
we've had the mirror held up we're
really clear about what needs to change
we absolutely accept that it is not good
enough and we talk about if it's not
good enough for our own children why
should it be good enough for us it for
children we stand we've actually
absolutely embraced that and I think
what we've managed to do as a system now
with the support of shown is really on
pick and phase and Stage what
improvements need to take place so
hopefully you found the report
um as as helpful as it can be but happy
to take questions now thank you thanks
Karen yeah I'm absolutely as you know we
did a lot of task and finish work on the
um sense of four or five years ago now
and I'm pleased to see that how much of
some of our recommendations have been
implemented
um but yeah the the outcome has just
improved incredibly hasn't it in the
last few years does anybody have any
questions
okay now let's start with Council of
prophet
I've got lots of questions well I'll try
not to do an ammo because she nicked all
my questions earlier on
so
first of all what's the delay between a
request being made for an assessment the
assessment happening and then the
recommendations being implemented for
any child
so
in terms of assessment which is can I
ask which assessment we're referring
sorry to that um ehp ehcps so a request
Sally should I bring you in on that
level
um are you just talking in general are
children at this age range or um so our
starting point Sorry at any point during
a child's life when a request comes in
for an assessment so in general terms so
our statutory
um time scales are that we need to make
a decision within six weeks of receiving
a request we have had a big increase in
Parental referrals recently so those
parental referrals we're trying to make
sure we've got some school information
as well alongside the parental referrals
range from very minimal information
because statutorily people only have to
give us a name and address and a school
a date of birth and obviously that's not
enough information to make any decision
on so sometimes we are looking for we've
got a parent form that sits on our local
offer that we prefer parents fill in so
there will they send that straight away
and then we follow up and give the
schools 10 days big things around the
holidays are always tricky so we've had
some slow ones because of the the
six-week break because we're waiting for
schools who have kind of you know got a
few now where we're chasing schools to
make sure we've got some information so
we can make the right decision but we'll
try and make those within six weeks I
haven't got the dates with me at the
minute as far as how many we're making
six weeks but that's something we can
get
I have to take my glasses off to read
specifically looking looking at the
transition from
um child to adult
this
part of the report really bothered me
because we're letting our kids stand
and we we must
improve
and
I never want to to read this again
how are you going to make sure that
we how are you going to evaluate whether
the plans you put in place actually make
a difference
foreign
alluded to we've got an Ambitions plan
to send ambition four is my lead one of
the things that we're doing is aligning
all of the actions and the ambition with
some performance metrics but the biggest
measure of performance metrics is what
do our children and young people say
that's different one of the challenge in
traffic at the moment is in PFA
children's voice is not loud enough and
it's not clear enough and it's not
consistent enough so parent voices is is
strong in some parts although we put
lots of parents who don't have positive
experience as a PFA but children and
people's voice in particular is isn't is
not it's not that strong so for me that
is that that has got to be the biggest
measure of success how do we understand
what this looks and feels like for
children there are things we can count
but really counting is for senior
leaders and strategic plans and lived
experience and what this feels like
differently for children and young
people and how much we understand that
is is the way that we come the real
count so the work and we've already
started will very much be about
involving parents and carers but also
children young people about what this
looks and feels like and how will we
know and look and feel differently now
one of the challenges for send is we
talk about it like it's one big thing
and it it's lots of different things and
it's different for different children
and people so it's a I keep talking to
the team about chunking it up that's my
Clumsy language about thinking about
what this looks like in different
cohorts of children people for
mainstream children there are some
different challenges to children who are
in special schools for example
collecting voice of children who may be
articulate and able to do that looks
different for children with Santa who
may not have speech for example that
doesn't mean their voice doesn't count
but we have to do those things
differently so we're trying really hard
to align the Ambitions with some hard
metrics but also with some um
lived experience metrics into as well
what how does this look and feel
differently and I'll be really honest
there is a journey to go that is
we keep laughing about my six months yet
it you know what they're
that deliverable will take longer than
that period of time to be consistent
about it that is just a fact because you
don't do something properly in that
period of time you don't but we will
start to see some measurable differences
and some of the things we put in play
for example a complex pathway we can
already measure some of that difference
in a very short period of time but that
on its own is is not enough and we need
to be if we're serious about being
ambitious for children to send we've got
to be ambitious about the metrics
um can I can I just come in as well
counselor Proctor one of the other
things we have done is strengthen
governance and Leadership and strategic
oversight so we've actually as part of
the the refresh of the Ambitions plan
and and our Improvement Journey we've
refreshed the terms of reference for the
Strategic sunboard now and so we've
we've we've really got a level of
seniority so we've got kind of the moves
and shakers as I call it on the board
who can absolutely influence Challenge
and also decision make
um that board will feed up to the
locality board and we'll have a link
into the health and well-being as well
so we've tried to strengthen the
governance and the other bit we do have
a chief exec lead member Assurance Group
which obviously Council councilor Carter
as well as other lead members attend
with the chief exec with the leader of
the council uh and and that is
absolutely around to Performance
Management of the system and driving for
that accountability so I think that the
metrics the ambition and the Strategic
governance hopefully we've got the
conditions right for that challenge and
level of accountability
that's great thank you I'm not
interested in
um oh no I am interested in numbers but
what I'm much more interested in is
lived experience because that's what
matters that we don't have
um
our vulnerable children and their
families lifetime we have them being
supported cared for and that they know
what the future holds for them and
not appropriate we aim on pet any
welcome
to you as well
thank you counselor
thank you
uh yes thank you thank you for this
report
um and thank you for including the
detail about earlier transitions in it
because it's so important to acknowledge
that this is about transitions to
adulthood even decades to come as well
as those that are imminent
um
actually one is I've got a question I
haven't prepared but it was um on
hearing the talk about uh spike in the
xcp referrals in uh secondary age
um
yes to absolutely focus on uh starting
early and focus on the early years are
so important back in July meeting I
commented on the data about the
percentage of the FCPS in each year
group uh and while it increases uh uh as
as the as the age groups get older
um there was far less increase through
first off PS2 and then a jump second off
he's stage two and
um that was explained in that meeting as
being about preparation for high school
and the transition
um
if if there's then also a spike in high
school it's just I mean that's not
really explanation for what's going on
in the uh primary age uh and for why
there's that difference between one
lucky stage two and another and I'm just
wondering if the earlier if the focus on
uh starting early
is there's something there's too much
tapering off and then a focus again
later on and we're Miss we're missing a
crucial point there at the middle of
prime Primary School uh where things are
not being picked up on early enough or
not being picked up in a formal way
um it's not something I'm expecting and
if you want to Bible about but
um yeah it just seems that there's too
many too many spikes to make sense as
something that's strategic
I think um I think when Karen said there
was this back at secondary she was
partly top of that transition to a
secondary right okay we're going to the
same Spike at the end of primary as we
did last time right okay yeah I would
say
there is another
Point around year nine you know moving
into key stage four
um especially around the social
emotional needs I think something
hundred
um exam pressure on problems I would
suggest but you know that's very
informal thoughts about that but um yeah
there was definitely an increase there
yeah but it's changing Key Stage really
those points which do
um tend to put the pressure on I suppose
as far as what's coming next to that for
that new person so that fits in with a
good plan which doesn't fit as you've
quite rightly say it really fits in with
PFA planning yeah because that's still
that's good for it to be at the end of
each kiss just feels like it's a bit
chasing the Tower or rather than trying
to catch up with things rather than it
really yeah happening
when it weapons are really needed it's
just before they've only gone to another
um another another
oh gosh
um regarding the year six to uh year
seven uh transition
because I wanted to ask about that
because there's the statutory deadline
which uh the vast majority being met in
February
um but then there's a window for
February due to the engine ps6 where
things could change but
um needs identified needs the identity
what is identified can change
um uh
children can enter into the fcpa
purposes the first time I just wanted to
ask what the processes are for where
something's changed uh significantly
that they affect what's an appropriate
es7 setting how is that dealt with after
that February identify
I think
um generally close enough generally
parents and all schools will parents
will usually contact school about that
or speak to the EHC coordinator I mean
there are some
those percentages are quoted there were
children that were already in the system
you know because that's what the
February deadline applies to obviously
there are some children coming up during
the year during year six with new EHC
plans that's more of a challenge because
the whole February deadline is to avoid
the normal school admissions isn't it
and type your transition done and dusted
and you know where you're going I think
usually things that most things that
have come up in between for those that
have already got a plan haven't
necessarily changed the destination not
not many change the destination but it
might need additional planning you know
so it's looking at the provision on
whether things need to be tweaked but
the secondary schools I think that's
something again that we're looking at
the consistency of a lot of the
secondary schools have changed and added
additional transition days in the last
few years for children but I was
speaking to a parent not long ago who
said it still feels like they're mainly
aimed at children with a plan what about
the children of scn support are they
getting the additional days they you
know some of those if we're aiming for
some children to not need a plan why
should they they should be able to get
good provision SEO support then we need
to take that across all of our offers
don't we and make sure that we're not
excluding them from a good transition
just because they haven't got to plan
because they might not you know that
might be irrelevant they should get that
anyway so some schools are doing that
well some some not just not offering
such a wide offer so that's something
that we're picking up with our secondary
schools yeah so if there's if there is
if for somebody with an existing hcp
there is a significant change in uh
identified support needs after February
it sounds like there isn't a specific
process that's followed I think we just
encourage encourage communication with
this enco at school and then with the AC
coordinator in the central team just
alert us tell us what's changed and then
if there's another review that sorry if
there's another review needed they can
hold it into a review before the end of
the year if necessary yeah is that it is
there any guidance provided to the
secretary about this
um
guidance or so I can take that back and
we can put something out yeah there you
go thank you yeah thank you
similar question but I'm always going to
be far more difficult to answer about
the post 16 transition there for
adulthood
um again what happens where there's
significant changes three year ten year
11 new new identified needs and so on
how systematic is it that new new things
are taken abroad and
a particularly dealt with
um I've got I'm aware of one case where
there's particular changes
halfway through year 11 which totally
changed what was appropriate from post
16 setting
um and it
went very wrong so it's like
um what happens when something
significant is identified at that stage
of the year 11. well again it suppose
it's all down to communication and I
know we've got improvements to make on
that as far as it's also sort of
managing expectations as far as what
change of setting might be required
making sure we really understand the
need to in order to to do that because
um
the the I suppose there's a lot of use
of alternative provision at the moment
that again we're kind of under pressure
to make sure we're very careful about
that and limited in our use of it on the
other hand sometimes that's what my
suits it might be what a parent wants so
it's getting the balance right of the
kind of pressure from everybody quite
rightly about how relevant and safe that
provision is
um as well as is that the only provision
that can meet need and thinking of um to
keep having conversation with shown
about focusing on what the provision is
rather than the placement and thinking
about what that that's that's like but
there is um there's a limit as well
about what's out there at the moment I
suppose for a lot of young people who
are struggling with attendance and
um you know they're planning the right
type of provision is a challenge but
we'd very much like to keep the
communication channels open and speak to
parents as soon as possible I think
we've had you know I've we have had some
complaints I've answered complaints
where we've agreed that we've not
communicated at the right times perhaps
action's been going on back at their
management people haven't said this is
where we're at this is where we're at
and kept them informed on a regular
basis so that's an area of improvement
that definitely challenges
and I'm just aware of the council at any
um have been waiting quite a while so
Council on any situated
there we go thank you chair thank you
very much for the report and all the
hard work that goes on every day
um there really are growing pressures on
Sunday and and much more coming down the
tracks uh because of the pandemic
there's not much to buy the resources
that's coming back from central
government
and well just on the key stage four
outcomes
[Music]
the national average which was a fall of
just under a percent so are we concerned
about that and uh what do we think that
contributing factors are behind that
icon
so I think one of the challenges you'll
notice one of the challenges in the
cohorts of data is sometimes it can be
very cohort dependent in terms of your
numbers
I haven't done a lot of this work
nationally in terms of what this looks
like outcomes educational outcomes for
children in Trafford with censor support
and hcps are very very good compared to
what you usually see lots of local
authorities are well below the national
average in terms of that outcome so I
think sometimes it's quite it's quite
difficult because you get cohort
dependencies in terms of some of your
variation in your data and sets and and
that's not about not being ambitious
for those children but it is about kind
of understanding how those needs are
changing one of the challenges I think
in Trafford and one of the things that
we need to get better at is
understanding the data behind the data I
know that sounds for tough but
understanding the cohorts of young
people that do really well and what we
can learn from that but also those
cohorts who don't do so well and there
is a merging
um needs Karen alluded to it earlier in
terms of some of our children and people
in traffic who are
um autistic but who are emotionally
based school avoiders and but also who
are who have academic ability but really
struggle to access curriculum and manage
so I I suspect although I haven't we've
got to do the deed I realized underneath
I suspect that that's driving a lot of
the national and and local outcomes
because those the numbers of those
children since the pandemic are really
increasing and
I I don't think we've quite got it right
in terms of our response for those those
children and and that's what parents are
saying really loudly and so Karen and I
were with and council card read the
parent camera Forum this morning that's
all the conversation that that dominated
nearly all of it and that that very
frustration that the children are
academically able but not accessing
um and I think that's probably there's
some data behind the data to really
understand that kind of property in
terms of where children are doing really
well and why they are but also where
children are not doing so well and why
why that might be so are we talking the
right things in the right places and to
schools or schools doing that but
overall I would say I couldn't believe
today when I came here I compared to
learning everywhere else you know it is
really from an educational outcome
perspective it's really impressive
and I think and that tells you a lot
about your school yeah yeah I think as
well you can look at the attainment aid
score for me the most importantly is the
progress
or because it is absolutely the starting
point s of these children which place
back into that co-host specific uh piece
of data and that might be something that
we haven't got the p8 scores for the Sun
so I'll absolutely make sure that those
are shared if that will be helpful
because I think for me that is the most
significant indicator rather than
attainment
thank you um
just to mention we have got school
accents on the agenda for the next week
so we're a bit uh Council Duncan request
um with references with reference to um
ambition for
States and we will ensure that our young
people would send have the same
opportunities as all your people so that
they could have the same life outcomes
um in relation to this point
um what activity and play groups are for
special needs children is there a figure
as to how many play groups are allocated
or sent children and non-centered
children
so um just so I've got I've got Clarity
on that are you talking about sort of
early years Provisions or service
children yeah I mean I can certainly get
the data on that one thing that I will
say is when because sometimes we have
sufficiency pressures in the nursery in
the pvi in the early years sector and
just purely because of business uh and
and their ability to just manage their
business at the moment just because of
um sort of funding and recruitment
crisis etc etc so sometimes we do have
sufficiency issues what we have done
where we know there are known
sufficiency issues we've actually asked
this sector to prioritize children with
send
so we've deliberately asked them to
maintain provision for children with
more complex or additional needs but I
can come back with the data on that
that'd be helpful
that's great thank you very much okay
thank you
um
thank you thank you for the report
um just going back and talk about
communication a few times tonight
um so I just wanted to expand a bit more
around
um how that will be improved I um
commend the uh the report in terms of
what it says around you know working
with the communications and engagement
group and doing it collaboratively but
surely there are quick wins taking
communication in the past I wondered are
there any interim steps that can be
taken to improve that more quickly yeah
I mean you know as you've said the
Korean education and engagement group is
is the Forum I suppose by which we
because we've got men we've got family
members as well on on the Forum it's a
way of making sure that the
communication is infected but after the
messaging around as well as well because
sometimes what we say isn't it's not the
what it's the house sometimes that we're
not getting right so that is something
that we're working on one piece of just
simple communication that we're trying
to firm up really quickly is everything
around transition deadlines and so we've
already put a communication together for
families that know the dates for when
Arrangements need to be made so those
deadlines for post 16 as well as years
year seven transition dates
um and where to go if families are still
unsure or they need to seek additional
advice and support from the coordinator
so that's something that we've already
got in in scope now so the parents know
what to expect but I think I think the
other bit is US
attending some of the traffic parent
care of foreign engagement sessions
which is every month it's a really
effect it's very much a use that we did
so they are absolutely holding us to
account for what we claim to do or what
we've promised to do and that's
absolutely the right thing you know for
us to be part of and I think that's
helping getting the messaging right for
our families too
just I think one of the issues is about
communicating expectations so when you
communicate nothing
parents don't know what they're supposed
to be expecting or not and when you've
got challenges in the same system like
long waiting lists people just don't
understand the way it's in the waiting
the weight and the waiting and so that
then causes people to want to contact
services and then services are really
busy response into the fact that they
can't give them a deadline that we're in
a bit of a snowball so some of the wins
are about being really clear about
levels of expectation my son was
referred to a scan and I got elect from
the nhsc and you're going to be at least
three months before you hear anything
don't fall you know don't phone us which
might not have been the greatest
communication but I wasn't expecting
anything one of the challenges
incentives were not clear enough and
that's what parents are saying we
understand everything can't come now and
but we want you to be much clearer with
us about what we can expect and what we
can't now not everyone will like that
but it there's something about Clarity
in terms of that the other thing that
we're doing is making sure that
communication is across the system so
this isn't just about what council staff
communicate this is about what everyone
working in the same system communicates
and making sure that that's clear and
consistent and and so that's one of the
other things that we need to be really
really good and clear about we are
working on some practice standards for
send generally and one of those will be
on communication particularly around
what you can expect and why you can
expect it and what you can do but also
what what won't happen so you know we we
won't contact you all day we'll contact
at these sort of levels because that's
one of the things that parents are
saying that communication is very
reactive so when they complain and they
shout that gets really good and but when
they're waiting that that's not very
good and what they want is much clearer
communication and that's something we
can we can Rectify so yeah we're on with
that but it's totally faceted so that's
really helpful I'm just wondering um
when that when that exists that come
here could that be really helpful you
know when we when we're out talking to
the residents
[Music]
which uh I've got one question I'm sorry
again
my memory and our last meeting I asked
about co-opted members
and for that we don't have any and a
governance officer
said that
um we had we advertised the positions I
was wondering have we had any response
to the Future
[Music]
starting around that we've not gone up
to advertise that because I have
contacted the governor's services that
we utilize
um but I've not received anything
content in the price and I've not
received any communication so I will
actually hit up with um Karen and
hopefully she has be able to because I
think Karen works with government
services a bit more line so if you can
help and get in contact with that um
is
yeah brilliant thank you very much and
so yeah we are looking into it but it's
just that we need the support for the
services because we don't have contacts
with like many of the schools as they're
through a uh Academy basis
sorry Karen I do need to keep you for
the wrap yeah
don't go yet sorry
it seems strange it seems strange to not
have Jill here
um
so at the last meeting
um we presented a task and finish report
on plums
um now since then
um when we start working on these tasks
can finish
projects
you will appreciate it spread over a
period of time
um and after the meeting it suggested
that we had another meeting with
officers because basically things have
moved on from when we started that so
that there will be some changes to the
document so with the permission of this
committee are you happy
um
to allow this report
to be amended as a delegated decision
for the task and Finnish group to make
um
there are a few minor changes in
adjustments and updates but with the
committee's permission I can go back to
the task and finish group and if you're
happy for us to
um authorize the report to go ahead if
it's all right
yeah everybody happy with that yeah okay
the next item on the gender is the work
program
which is part of the document pack
is there any of it there's always room
to tackle anything that comes up that's
um is topical or urgent
um but are people happy with the stuff
that we've got on the work plan
so far
um we've got placement planning
for the next meeting School absence and
we've got the report form
um complex complex safeguarding the
annual report
um
and then we've got the January meeting
but if anybody thinks of anything in
between that they would like to raise
if you just let
um it could be Harry and myself no more
than happy to add it to the agenda if we
think it's pertinent
is that all right with everybody
okay and
um we don't normally have urgent
business but because this is such a
topical item and it it's
in the public domain at the moment
there's been a lot of
um
interesting concern in this I have asked
um that we have a report on the position
with the Rack in in our schools so I
think Karen's going to talk us through
that yeah um I mean it was um you know
quite quite a slim report but hopefully
it's it's provided sufficient
information for you to to be assured
um obviously you know what what has set
out there is some of the I suppose
because it's been considered over a
period of time really since 2018 and
it's kind of been on the agenda really
and the DFE has been working with
schools and responsible bodies to to
manage the potential risk of rack and
obviously the responsible body dependent
upon the status of the status of the
school will differ and we are the
responsible body for Community
Foundation and voluntary control schools
in Trafford
um obviously the diocese is is the
responsible body for any faith schools
voluntary aided schools and the relevant
trust for academies so I've highlighted
there some of the technical guidance
that has been issued to schools and
responsible bodies over time
clearly things things ramped up really
over the summer and it was it did feel
at the time quite reactive actually it
was the last week before the schools
came back and suddenly there was a
flurry of activity and Communications in
from DFE to the local Authority about
the position of schools and I think
certainly that really raised some
anxiety levels for our families and
children as well as our our schools and
what I would say is the school's Capital
team have had a really firm grip on our
schools as we are the responsible body
they'd already undertaken a desktop
exercise using the asset management
information that they have on our
schools to first of all establish which
buildings fell in scope for potential
rack and obviously we could eliminate
those because of their their age and
their structure profile
um we absolutely made sure as well that
really we reiterated the importance for
other schools not just our maintained
schools but for our faith schools and
academies to ensure that they'd
fulfilled the questionnaire the surveys
that the DFE were requesting and just so
that again there was a level of
assurance provided and we actually
chased all of our schools even those we
weren't responsible for to make sure
that that had been done we're
responsible then for 39 schools and of
those none of our schools have required
any form of temporary or emergency
accommodation as a result of rack we've
actually gone back and we've done
further intrusive testing where we've we
were concerned DFE I think raised two
schools where they were a little bit
concerned about the presence of Iraq so
intrusive testing took place that we
commissioned and again no rack was
identified
as I've said in the report there were
two schools
um Altrincham college and sale grammar
that were impacted but that had actually
been identified a few months ago so the
schools were able to put mitigating
um sort of systems in place uh to to
prevent any disruption to education so
it didn't require any closure and
foreclosure of the schools and obviously
they're going to be working with the DFE
because they are academies and to put in
now whatever measures it needed to to
resolve some of those issues building
issues that exist within their settings
um and basically where again we there
was a couple of schools that we were
aware of again uh within a trust
um where they hadn't completed the
questionnaire we worked with the dfv and
with the schools to make sure that that
was done and submitted in time and we've
constantly Linked In with DFE to make
sure that any outcome of of those
surveys
um if there were any concerns from our
perspective and non-non have been raised
we're also aware of manner one of our
special schools did have to close one
day that was so that the intrusive
testing the surveys could be done I
think they were concerned that because
of the level of need of the children
because it's a specialist setting they
weren't prepared to be open whilst those
testings took place which was a very you
know sensible option to take no rap was
identified so they reopened the day
after so actually in Trafford we feel
like you know we have such award and
done everything we can to support and
protect the schools
um and as I say it feels actually like
it's gone a bit client which is which is
unusual as well but and hopefully you
know you will feel assured that that has
been handled as well as it possibly
could by by the local Authority I think
the one interesting thing that it did
raise for us generally when we do our
quality assurance visits with schools
one of the questions that we are going
to be talking to them about is business
Prosperity plans because I think it's
only when these events come that you
begin to think about what will that mean
for our children and families whether
that's communication whether that's
remote education what temporary
accommodation where will children be
cited if they did have to move out of a
school so I think all of these
conversations it's good learning isn't
it for us and that is something that we
are going to pick up with heads
I feel reassured I was very concerned a
couple of weeks ago when I asked for
this to go on the agenda does anybody
have any questions on the reports
well thank you again
um
unless there are any more questions from
the and Pacific committee
I'm going to close the meeting and wish
you all a safe journey home thank you
foreign